ça y est l'expérimentation des navettes
autonome est lancé dans l'agglomération
de saint quentin en yvelines
lalime 490 a été inauguré ce mercredi 31
mars par les élus elle devient la
première ligne de bus du réseau
francilien entièrement opéré avec des
navettes autonome et électriques
mais pas seulement c'est
l'expérimentation en situation réelle in
avril life comme disent les jeunes
aujourd'hui en situation réelle avec des
obstacles à franchir des obstacles c'est
quoi c'est des ronds-points et feu rouge
ou bien ou bien l'affranchissement d'une
départementale avec 10000 véhicules qui
vont croiser la navette donc c'est la
première expérimentation en circulation
réelle en vrai circulation avec une des
impératifs de qualité de service comme
un vrai bus cette navette c'est le bus
de deux mamans un trajet d'un 1,6 km
sans conducteur donc ce nouveau moyen de
déplacement circulera toutes les 6 à 8
minutes en heure de pointe de 7h30 à 20h
la ligne 490 partira de la gare de saint
quentin en yvelines jusqu'à la zone
d'activités du pas du lac où se situe
plusieurs grosses entreprises
on essaie d'être innovant et on va
encore proposer des nouvelles solutions
bien sûr le transport c'est le coeur de
la compétitivité aussi économiques
de saint quentin on est dans les plus
gros pib par habitant en france après
paris donc bien sûr que c'est
c'est le point central on a dix sept
mille entreprises
à près de 140 mille salariés donc donc
bien sûr c'est une belle journée pour
nous
et surtout pour ligier au qui arrive
financé par ile-de-france mobilité à
hauteur de 2,4 millions d'euros et par
l'agglomération 130000 euros
ce test des navettes autonome va durer
deux ans reconductible
le service est d'ailleurs gratuit pour
les usagers